tu voulais dire ouais alors moi tu sa
j'ai l'émotion qui est un peu à son max
donc je sais pas si je vais tenir
euh d'abord je je tiens à te dire mon
cher frère Cyril que on condamne
totalement quelle que soit la barbarie
qu'il y a d'accord les tueries les
kidnappings ça on le condamne fortement
ce ne sont
pas 5 millions de Français de confession
de musulmanes qui qui soutiennent ça en
tout cas moi je vous le dis
personnellement parce que je suis pas un
clergé et je vais parler pour moi
euh ce qu'on est en train de vivre
effectivement est est juste abominable
que on peut soutenir on peut soutenir
bien évidemment les Palestiniens mais
que ce soit absolument pas de laamass
parce que nous on condamne les gens du
Hamas on peut aussi soutenir Israël sans
forcément adhérer au gouvernement
d'extrême droite de
netanahou que d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis
à moi que j'ai en Israël sont
totalement totalement contre et qui qui
veulent la paix les deux peuples veulent
la paix c'est c'est ni le Hamas et ni le
le le l'extrême droite on sait que
l'histoire a donné avec la colonisation
je pense qu'ici on a il y a certains
sémite ici peut-être que dans nos
famille on a eu des choses graves durant
la guerre en tout cas moi en tout cas
avec la colonisation en tout cas
l'Algérie française d'autres quion suivi
l'Holocauste j'ai des amis extrêmement
avec qui je suis frèrees dont certains
que vous avez reçu ici je peux vous en
citer la famille Broman la famille Madar
bar la famille minachem des gens avec
qui j'ai grandi AC qui on a fait du
sport et et tout ça j'ai la chance en
tout cas de de d'être là et que tu
puisses me donner la parole contre ça
euh moi je suis peiné absolu j'ai reçu
effectivement tu soulignais tout à
l'heure les réseaux sociaux qui se sont
totalement oparés de quelque chose où
j'ai reçu moi aussi des des menaces je
dis moi quand je vois sur les réseaux
mort aux Juifs mort aux Arabes là en ce
moment là sur les réseaux c'est
inadmissible je vous le dis franchement
c'est inadmissible on peut pas voir ça
je pourrais même pas te dire ce que ce
qu'on m'envoyit parce que je pense que
il y en a qui choperaiit une atite ici
mais nous en tout cas ce que je peux te
dire c'est que bah je vis dans le 20e tu
habitais au Lila dans le 20e il y a deux
synagogues euh ces synagogues n'ont
jamais été touché parce que les gens du
quartier dont moi je faisais partie
quand on allait prier le vendredi parce
qu'on avait le même chemin vous priez le
vendredi et nous aussi on prie le
vendredi on connaissait les parents
parce que ces parents-là nous ont gardés
ils nous ont vu grandir ils ont vu nos
parents aussi partir on les a vu partir
et je me refuse
totalement à à dire que aujourd'hui le
le combat c'est musulman à juif mais
bien au contraire c'est un combat qu'on
doit mener tous ensemble et
que lorsqu'on a commencé cette émission
le 4 septembre et qu'on avait
pardonnez-moi et je fais le parallèle
avec ça
j'en avais parlé à Valérie et à
Géraldine quand on a commencé avec la BA
et compagnie je sais pas si je vais
tenir parce que moi c'est les choses qui
me prennent à cœur et je sais pas si je
suis légitime dans cette émission
à à parler de ça donc moi je sais que
dans ma famille y en a qui ont beaucoup
souffert de la guerre je sais
qu'aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui
souffre il va y avoir des dommages
collatéraux parce qu'il y a des enfants
qui vont tout perdre des parents qui
vont tout perdre ça commence
ça dure depuis plus de 50 ans qu'est-ce
qu'il faut
faire j'ai pas la solution
personnellement parce que je suis pas un
spécialiste de de ce terrain là on est
là regarder avec les réseaux sociaux et
la télé et
puis la chance que j'ai eu moi en tout
cas dans dans mon enfance d'avoir grandi
avec cette France plurielle je pense à
David Chlomo
Philippe gens y ENF en tout cas toute
cette France plurielle on sait jamais
parler de ça jamais on a jamais parlé de
de guerre bien au contraire euh tu
citais tout à l'heure que tu voulais pas
que ton fils euh soit en guerre avec son
ami
Edy bah moi en 50 ans on NAA jamais
dérapé avec nos frères de franceç et de
confession juives et
euh j'ai vu une pièce de théâtre
dimanche on débattre ça bon visiblement
c'est un peu raté euh mais euh je prie
de tout cœur en tout cas pour que un
jour il y ait la paix et que chacun
puisse vivre de sa religion de ce qu'il
en soit je voulais juste mettre une P
bémole et ensuite j'arrêterai mon frère
cyil dans la rêve partie je pense qu'il
y av aussi des
Arabes qui étaent là il a aussi des
arabes qui sont médecins et qui qui qui
bossent en Israël et qui ont peut-être
aussi leur famille à Gaza et qui font
l'etour et que parfois le fait que ça
bombarde des deux côtés ben ils vont
plus retrouver leur famille compagnie
alors il faut faire quoi
moi j'ai pas voulu prendre partie tout
de suite sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que j'étais dans un moment de deuil je
savais que ça allait prendre un élan que
moi je ne maîtrise pas que vous ici vous
ne maîtrisez pas parce que nous moi je
ne vis pas à Gaza je ne vis pas en
Israël comme vous mais il y a
effectivement il y a aussi un lien qui
nous rapproche de là-bas soit il y a de
la famille soit il y a le côté religieux
des deux voilà ce que je dire je sais
pas si c'est technique ce que j'ai dit
mais en tout cas j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai vu
aussi je parlais avec un pote tout à
l'heure et je
disais comment tu veux empêcher les
personnes de confession juiv de défendre
Israël comment tu veux empêcher des
personnes de confession musulmanes de
pas mettre le drapeau palestinien non
mais c'est vrai comment tu veux faire
c'est
aujourd'hui j'ai vu des choses sur les
réseaux sociaux je vous dis qui font
extrêmement peur il s'est passé un drame
c'est des
attentats sans NOMON peut pas nommer qui
sont voilà c'est comme
Bataclan
c'est c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé si c arrivé en France je
dis c'est quelque chose voilà qui je
pense jamais arriv en France d'ailleursp
du
batac attentats
simultanés il faut d'abord
condamner et condamner quoi qu'il arrive
quand il y a
des victimes qui sont des civils qui
n'ont rien demandé quoi qu'il arrive la
première chose à faire c'est condamner
c'est ça et condamné sans mais ou de en
même temps ouais mais pas de mer je vois
beaucoup de gens là sur les réseaux qui
me disent est-ce que tu vas parler de la
France insoumise bien sûr que je en
parler de la France insoumise norm parce
que la France insoumise ça a été les
spécialiste du
Mai au départ il y avait même pas de mai
parce qu'au départ France souis n'a pas
condamné ces horribles attentats alors
je vois manuel bonpard des membres de la
France insoumis je vais en parler dans
un
instant qui s'est rétracté derrière qui
a fait un tweet où il dit qu'il voulait
voulait la paix et au départ il a il des
tweets très compliqué tout comme on va
parler de Louis Boyard mais bon Louis
Boyard je ve dire c'est un est
cervelé voilà il a il a plus de
moustache que de cerveau non mais c'est
ouais c'est lui à la limite
voilà c'est un guignol donc on va lui on
va Mme je sais même pas si on va parler
de lui non mais Emmanuel bonpard il dit
maintenant il veut la
paixel bonpard donc il dit à tout le
monde il faut faire la paix il faut
faire la paix il faut faire la paix bien
sûr qu' faut faire la paix tout le monde
veut la paix oui c'est mais déjà il faut
condamner les attentats qui ont été
perpétrés on est d'accord Yan soit c'est
de la crétinerie connaissent pas
l'histoire ou et non plus la géographie
soit c'est de l'électoralisme de bas
étage exement ou l'autre peut-être un
mélange je veux dire manuel bonpard il
arrive pas à arrêter de dealers dans les
Bouches du rô il va faire la paix dans
le monde écoutez si on compte après lui
non mais c'est vrai si on compte sur lui
je peux vous dire on a le temps de voir
des drames encore arriver donc on va en
parler dans un instant et je vais vous
reparler je vous dis de ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux
et on va se poser les cinq questions sur
ce qui s'est passé bien entendu et je
vous le redis parce que je vois beaucoup
de gens là sur Twitter qui ont pas
compris ce qu'on a dit qui disent font
l'amalgame entre les les musulmans et
les terroristes bien au contraire c'est
pas du tout ce qu' dit
contraire il faut éviter ça parce que je
vous dis
aujourd'hui j'ai eu j'ai eu j'ai plein
de potes même du métier qui m'ont
dit on on n pas envie de ça voil juif
prania aussi il faut éviter ça on est
que ça on est dans un truc aujourd'hui
où il faut qu'on soit ensemble rassemblé
et il a unetité s reuse qui s'appelle le
Hamas qu'empêche tout mouvement vers la
paix depuis maintenant 1987 voilà ce
qu'il faut dire point on va se retrouver
dans un instant on va se poser les cinq
questions sur cette attaque et il y aura
alin ber qui V venir qui va venir nous
rejoindre qui nous répondra à toutes les
questions à